[موسيقى]
سيخوض المنتخب المصري مواجهه الراس الاخضر
بحثا عن استعاده ادائه المعهود او هي
مباراه لا تقبل القسمه على اثنتين بعد
التعادل في مباراتين امام كل من موزمبيق
وغانا ورغم غياب نجمه وقائده محمد صلاح
بسبب الاصابه سيحاول الفراعنه تحقيق
الانتصار الذي يضمن لهم التاهل للدور
الثاني كوصيف للمجموعه الثانيه شايف بس ان
خلاص انا مش موجود الماتش الجاي اتمنى ان
شاء الله اي حد موجود ده اللي احنا قلناه
بين الشوطين الماتش اللي فات ان هو يادي
بشكل كويس ويحاول يكسب الفريق وده اهم
حاجه احنا ده منتخب مصر مش منتخب صلاح
صلاح واحد من ضمن 27 لعيب في المنتخب
ف ف شاايف ان ان شاء الله انا متفائل جدا
واللاعيبه اللاعيبه متفائله واتكلمنا مع
بعض و وان شاء الله نقدر نكسب ماتش بكره
اهم حاجه اما التعادل فسيدخل مصر في دائره
الحسابات وقد تغادر الدور الاول في واحده
من مفاجات البطوله القاريه وحسب تقارير
صحفيه سيحافظ مصطفى فتحي على مكانته في
التشكيله الاساسيه بعدما حل بديلا لنجم
ليفربول الانجليزي امام منتخب النجوم
السوداء اما منتخب الراس الاخضر فكانت
المفاجاه الساره في الكان فقد حقق التاهل
لدور ال 16 في صداره المجموعه بعدما حقق
فوزين مقنعين على غان وموزمبيق
[موسيقى]